bueno ahora les vamos a mostrar el
equipo de los que nos estaba hablando
oliver y bolivia para que tengan una
idea más clara de de qué era lo que nos
estaban diciendo porque en la radio
cuando estamos escuchando pues no
tenemos la imagen esta es la imagen
oliver que nos está mostrando sí claro
mira este es el traje de neopreno que
utilizamos para el zurrón es un traje
especial como pueden ver la semana viene
adelante para poder respirar cuando
hacemos el trote y trae aquí unos unos
bolsillos interiores para guardarla para
guardar alimentos o guardar cosas que en
otro otro a la parte de atrás tiene otro
otro vuestro dispositivo para conservar
también cosas y entre las piernas el
material no es neopreno sino una tela
para que la fricción no dañe no haya
rite y no irrite lo mismo lo mismo en
los lados
en los lados del traje entonces es un
traje especial no sigo diciendo que
viene acompañado por los zapatos
son unos zapatos también que también son
especiales
para este tipo de competencia el agua
sale inmediatamente cuando salimos a
trotar y
flotan son más súper ligeros flota
si estás para la natación eso que les
ayuda a nadar más rápido si no nos
mejora la tracción porque obviamente las
piernas van a estar comprometidas con él
con los zapatos los zapatos y esto que
es un flotador que va entre las piernas
para que el cuerpo se mantenga en un
nivel de flotabilidad entonces era lo
que decíamos en la entrevista que no
pueden mover las piernas como se hace
generalmente cuando se está nada se
tienen relatados las piernas quedan
fijas y la patada se cede se anula y el
todo el trabajo se convierte solamente
en trabajo superior los brazos y
guardamos las piernas para la parte de
socio y entonces sea cesada de esa
alternada
se alterna de esa forma
y bueno esto es básicamente ahí hay
modificaciones hay personas que usan
otros otras cosas pero la base del
zurrón es básicamente el traje los
zapatos y las paletas y el público
bueno entonces ya para que ustedes
tengan una idea de lo que se requiere
para hacer swing marrón y si quieren
inscribirse o si quieren competir acá
tenemos los expertos que los van a
ayudar sólo tienen que escribirnos y
nosotros le pasamos la información
muchísimas gracias oliver y olivia
gracias por invitación